[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview it's our first look at
saturday's front pages
and it's time to see what's making the
headlines with the daily mirror
economist susie pontface and the
journalist and commentator sam ashworth
hayes they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight a very good evening
to you we'll chat in a moment after
we've had a look at some of those front
pages for you starting with the ft
leading with the rise in the energy
price cap saying millions face energy
poverty as household bills set to surge
by 80 percent
well it's going to be a catastrophe
that's what the mirror is saying the
rise in the energy price cap will become
as they call for the government to act
meanwhile the express quotes prime
minister boris johnson that a pipeline
of cash is on the way to struggling
households
the mail says energy hikes may wipe out
savings for six million people
lives will be lost warns the front of
tomorrow's guardian in reference to the
hike in energy prices set to come in in
october
here's tomorrow's eye reporting on liz
trust's u-turn on energy handouts saying
she's set to give extra winter fuel
payments to pensioners
and the telegraph focusing its attention
on the chancellor's take on the energy
price cap with the headline middle class
need energy bills help says zahavi
and the times also has the energy crisis
on its front warning of double digit
inflation for a year with the headline
energy bills hit three and a half
thousand pounds with worst yet to come
and don't forget you can scan the qr
code that you can see on screen
throughout the programme check out the
front pages while you listen to us
discussing them and to discuss them
susie boniface and sam ashworth hayes
thanks for being with us on well i have
to say it's a pretty depressing evening
all the front pages are going with the
cost of living crisis with this uh news
today the huge hike
in the uh the price cap suzy uh front of
the mirror our whole country is facing
an energy bills catastrophe for heaven's
sake do something pictures there of
boris johnson liz trust and rishi sunak
the government susie of course would say
that they have already done something
and more help is on the way
well what government exactly now the
mirror has been reporting
all week
on succession of voices from charities
from business from energy firms from uh
politics and from across the you know
across the spectrum of british life
really as well as individual families
and people and and businesses
all demanding something to be done and
you know this morning when we woke up
and heard the news that the energy price
cap was perhaps going to hit six and a
half thousand pounds next year
the first thing i did when i got out of
bed was walk around the house turning
off everything i could find right i just
switched everything i didn't need it i'm
gonna switch that off from now on that's
it that we're gonna have to at least
that's the start of things and at the
same time in the house of every single
tory government minister they were
switching off their phones they were
ignoring their emails they were avoiding
the airwaves and seeing as these people
are normally quite happy to spout and
blow and expel some hot air
out into the world they stayed very very
quiet this morning and they went into
hiding quite literally
because they just didn't want to have to
explain how we got to this point which
is decades decades of lack of planning
and preparation
and what they're going to do about it
which is we don't know and the reason
they don't know is because they're
having a self-indulgent bit of tory
turmoil over
who's the right person to replace an
absolute liar in parliament
and they're not walking around turning
off their charges at the sockets because
because that's they'll save them 50
pence because this this is a government
by people who have never been short of
50 pence they've never been at the till
and had to put something back on the
shelf because they couldn't afford it
for the sake of 50 pence and so they
these are the people who are trying to
work out what they can do to help us but
they can't make these decisions because
they don't have a prime minister the
prime minister they do have isn't
prepared to make the decision either and
so this is just it's just getting worse
and worse and even if they do come up
with something in the next few
weeks and months to come
there are people who are going to be
going into this winter
terrified
and that terror is going to mean that
they are not turning the heating on and
it means that they're going to be more
anxious and it means they're more likely
to commit suicide and it means they're
going to get too cold it means they're
not going to eat well enough and it
means they're going to get more chest
infections and it means they're going to
die because of the fear that is being
spread and it's not being
handled by a government that is just
able to go onto the airwaves and speak
to us like grown-ups
did speak susie today didn't he the
problem to be fair to the prime minister
he did actually speak today
in the end yeah yeah yeah um sam started
a leader rubbish
the headlines are depressing they don't
get any better on the front of the
guardian lives will be lost we are in a
state of limbo when it comes to
uh the governance of the country we
still have to wait ten days or so before
we know who the next prime minister will
be
are you confident that
the help that clearly is needed and that
does have to come will be able to get to
people in time
i don't think it's a matter of timing so
much as whether they actually know what
they're going to be doing
um right now it seems like the plan for
the winter is hope for good weather uh
we don't have a a sort of patch of
support being proposed for households
yet i know there's there's some
discussion that this trust may make an
extra into fuel payment for pensioners
well that's fine but it's not going to
address
the needs of some of the lower income
households or even as we're discussing
shortly some of the middle income
households who will need additional help
and there's almost no discussion of what
we're going to be doing to assist
businesses through this or even if we
are going to be assisting them through
this
um there are people sort of saying that
what we need to do here is let the free
market take its course allow that to
allocate things um which is all well and
good as a principle um that we don't
have a completely free marketing energy
it's very state regulated it's very
states um
governed we have this price cap for
residential consumers which makes uh
energy cheaper for them that would be
for businesses so already putting a
thumb on the scale in that direction and
of course we're also going to be
subsidising through the winter because
they need to be able to heat their homes
um and so this this sort of idea you can
basically just do tax cuts and you know
redistribute households that way and
then leave to that i think it's just
woefully insufficient and i think
we we need to hear something from trust
and tsunac and what their plan would be
yeah this is the thing sam is that we're
hearing a lot from people who are
experts in this field who've got some
ideas who really do want to help there's
dale vince miko tricity there's martin
lewis the money-saving expert they've
been talking about what you could do
right now to give an energy cap to help
small businesses because they are
completely uncapped and they're going to
the wall and the economic cost of that
will be immense they're talking about
uncoupling electricity prices some of
which is very cheap because it's from
renewable sources from the gas prices
they're tied to at the moment which are
insanely expensive so that the overall
price does come down a bit for us
they're talking about capping the
profits you can make out of north sea
oil and things like this for example to
two percent which is what the price cap
is setting there's lots of people who
want to come forward who you could
easily get onto a committee of experts
as we did with covid you know we had the
experts all came out we had sage and
said well these are the best things to
do and they present the plans to the
prime minister and the cabinet and they
chose which one to do despite what risky
soon act says
um what we could do that with the energy
experts we could do that with the with
the energy companies and with the
charities and with the people who are
representing consumers and it's not
happening and that doesn't require you
to choose who the prime minister is you
can still have the entertainment do you
not think susie the treasury is is the
treasury not doing this right now um um
nadeem zahawi uh today uh said you know
a lot of work is going on behind the
scenes the treasury's surely are
crunching the numbers and speaking to
experts and trying to work out a number
of different scenarios so that they are
ready to go when liz trust will really
soon act take the keys to number 10.
well there's two problems with that the
first is uh just the group thinking
within whitehall which means that the
treasury just has this long-established
inability to spend other people's money
it wants to sit on it instead
and secondly it's the fact that you've
got whoever the prime minister is going
to be an ideological unwillingness to
spend money on people
so they they want to give tax cuts they
want to let you have keep more of your
own money they don't want to give any of
it back that seems to be anti them and
so that's a
there's a hurdle you have to get over
mentally to convince the likes of liz
trust or rishi sunak whoever it might be
in their governments to actually you
know do as as rishi did in government
undercover to have a furlough scheme to
start going well you know stuff free
market we're going to have to have a big
intervention and that's a huge jump that
they just don't seem to be making yet
okay and meanwhile as the mirror is
showing people are really scared okay um
i just want to talk uh about the front
of the daily telegraph uh next because
you mentioned this sam uh nadeem zaha
were also saying today that the middle
classes will need energy bills help
yeah absolutely um i think we're sort of
really
underestimating the extent which is
really quite damaging for consumers if
we just focus on the very bottom of the
income distribution because there will
be a lot of people
whose budgets are already being
relatively strained by inflation who are
going to really feel the pinch when
their pills start rocketing um and the
idea that we can kind of save lots of
energy i think is
i mean it may be born out but
historically energy demand in britain
from household consumers is really
inelastic and well that basically means
if prices go up 10 and use comes down
one percent so if you're basically
relying on people finding ways to save
energy what that means then turning up
the heat
and that's exactly what we don't want to
be doing in the winter
um but the sort of the core problem here
is when he says we're going to support
households um which is which is probably
what we should be doing
um that implicitly comes at the expense
of business because what we're basically
talking about here is how we're going to
allocate the limited supply of energy we
have
um and the more you tip the scale one
way so the more people who are able to
heat their homes
the flip side to that is the higher the
cost benefits for businesses and the
more of them will be going to the wall
so you end up with this sort of choice
of do you heat your home or do you keep
your job um and it's a it's a really
unfortunate position for anybody to be
in particular one just coming in but the
fact that it could be this severe this
winter is why we really need to start
knowing now what we can expect um you
know business plans make households have
budgets to make um and the fact that
we're just in limbo while borrow sort of
swans around on holiday is just it's
beyond disgraceful yeah um it's an
interesting headline that isn't it about
the middle classes on the front the
telegraph because actually um susie it's
also
what kierstama has been saying in a way
because his idea freezing the uh uh the
price cap um will uh
help the richest as well as the poorest
but but he hasn't got a problem with
that
no he he's he's happy with that they've
done their sums and that's what they've
come up with it was a lib dem idea
originally and it took a while for
labour to come around to it but they
seemed to be making more noise than the
lib dems did
um but you know it's the middle classes
that vote
unfortunately uh and the poor people
generally are less likely to vote and so
this is the the part of the um the
electorate the demographic which people
are really going to care about likewise
older people pensioners on fixed incomes
uh who you know aren't going to be able
to go out and earn a bit of extra money
aren't going to be able to do an extra
shift to pay for this
and we're also going to be looking at
you know increased death rates from
people who are more likely to get cold
more likely to have chest infections
more likely to be malnourished perhaps
over the winter and possibly if you tie
that in with some kind of a covered
surge maybe not you know a terrible
strain but even a mild strain in this
situation could be really quite
devastating yeah and that's something
that people really need to start
thinking about as well okay i just want
to look at the eye as well sam uh trust
u-turn on energy handout she was
avoiding the cameras today she has help
she has said help will come immediately
if she wins the leadership race uh also
talk that potentially she could boost
universal credit but this u-turn is
about uh winter fuel payments to
pensioners
exactly so um
you know it's something rather than
absolutely nothing although i'm not sure
it's actually been formally announced
yet as opposed to still being discussed
as sources um but
there are a lot of people who are going
to need help who aren't pensioners
they're going to be sort of single
parent families who will be facing real
financial strain there are going to be
people who are out of work on benefits
or disabled who are going to need this
help as well so the fact that we're
still sort of um framing this through
the pensioners and again like to you
know to return to the electoral dynamics
of this it makes sense to the
conservative party or the cops they're
called first
but um we do need to know what's going
to be done for everyone else
telegraph uh sam and uh the paper
revealing the possible cabinet under liz
trust and a few big names aren't going
to be very happy
no absolutely not and obviously the so
the major casualty here is pretty patel
who um apparently has sort of been
saying she'll only take the role of him
secretary she doesn't want to be moved
along
and it seems like trust is basically
going to be moving in some of her own
loyal figures
into place from her own government and
some of the names being suggested really
interesting uh we have um
kenny bayden apparently this is possibly
up for ministerial brief i've got a
quasi-crossing so it it sort of looks
like um it's going to be quite a new
look at the top of the conservative
party and hopefully
um in an optimistic way i'm sort of
hoping we get some sort of more free
market policy outside than we've had
over the last few years
susie your thoughts
well um it says here that you know
pretty patel's on her way out it doesn't
quite say why which of course is the
fact that she's failed miserably at
everything she's been asked to do for
the last few years
um and the home office is just a boston
case anyway whoever runs it but uh
someone else is going to get that poor
job maybe can be bad knock but it
doesn't say in here is that it was
rumored i think last week i don't know
if it was ever um stamped out but that
the new leveling up secretary was going
to be jacob brie smog which sounds like
i just assumed that was a terrible
internet joke when i heard it but then
it did seem to be a serious suggestion
in one of the
sunday papers that he he was going to be
the person in charge of making sure
everyone had a fair crack of the whip in
the uk which is
interesting well we shall find out uh um
and not and not very long when we it's
only a lesson less than two weeks time
and talking of liz trust there's another
story on the front the telegraph this is
uh referring to uh the hustings that
were held when she was asked the
question quite a good question i thought
sam president macron friend or foe and
there's been quite a lot of diplomatic
fallout as a result of her answer
yeah um possibly a slightly too blunt
answer when she said the jury is out um
but then you know macron's saying oh
we're going to have serious problems if
we can't tell the front of britain the
friends of enemies um i don't think
anyone's saying that i think everyone's
considered there to be a strong
relationship between france and britain
military cooperation economic
cooperation for the most part
um whether or not that translates as we
think emmanuel macron can be trusted to
act on our interest is an entirely
different matter um although i get i
guess the thing about that is you may
well think it uh the advisability of
saying it when you're about to become
prime minister is another matter
entirely um and i thought it was quite a
strange response in that they're
you know the votes are basically already
cast there's really not much need to be
doing this sort of them playing to
select the roads so quite why she sort
of felt the need to come out and say it
quite as button as she did is it's
something of a mystery to me yeah what
happened there susie was she just caught
on the hoof
the fact that this is the person who's
going to be the prime minister it's not
that she's not saying things because she
thinks that the thing she needs to say
to get elected she's saying things
because she genuinely thinks this stupid
stuff and what she thinks in this
particular instance is oh the french
which is what people have been thinking
in this country for about a thousand
years i think pretty much since 1066 and
by the way they were vikings
but ever since you know it's like our
rulers have to you know the plantagenets
were half in france and half here and
our taxes went over there and all that
and that whole argument just was the
wounds were reopened by the brexit
debate and now they're being used to
constantly have a fight with the french
it's the french's fault for this it's
the gas prices the french's fault so
they're nuclear reactors that's the
fault if the migrants is all their fault
they're not doing enough they were
tear-gassing migrants on the beach at
calais in today's papers they're doing
quite a bit
um but not to sit there and say i don't
know if his friend or foe emmanuel
macron if anybody doesn't realize he's
actually a center-right politician you
know he's on the conservative side of
things and for someone who's a
conservative to go well i didn't want to
talk to him it's just the kind of stupid
thing that pretty patel's been doing for
the last three years with no purpose
whatsoever and no success excuse me i'm
worried i'm already gonna burst a blood
vessel so i'm gonna i'm gonna line
things up with the mac cartoon sam just
talk us through this because it is a
funny one
yeah
so he he has nailed it again as they say
um he's sort of you know his email from
nigerian princess genuine the energy but
must be a scam i mean it really is
unbelievable how high prices are going
and how high they're going to go from
here although less for laughing matter
yeah exactly all right thanks both